I studied for an English test today and
learned 80 vocabulary words in ten days
I will have forgotten every word the
number of words that I remember t days
after studying is modeled by so W of T
so this is the number of words I have in
my head as a function of time is going
to be equal to 80 times the 1 minus 0.1
T squared for T is between 0 and 10
including the two boundaries that's why
we have back brackets right over here
what is the rate of change of the number
of words note of the number of known
words per day two days after studying
for the test and I encourage you to
pause this video and try it on your own
so the key here is we come up with this
equation for modeling how many words
have retained in my brain everyday after
I first memorize them after I got the 80
of them into my head and that's this
expression here and they want to know
the rate of change two days after
studying well the rate of change I can
take the derivative of this with respect
to time so let's do that so let's take
the derivative the derivative of the
number of words I know with respect to
time is going to be equal to well we
have this 80 out front that's just a
constant and now I can apply the chain
rule right over here so the derivative
of 1 minus 0.1 T whole thing squared
with respect to 1 minus 0.1 T is going
to be so I'm essentially taking the
derivative of this whole pink thing with
this this whole expression squared with
respect to the expression so that's
going to be 2 times 1 minus 0.1 T and
now I can find the derivative of this
inner expression with respect to T so
derivative of this inner expression with
respect to T is just going to be 0 minus
0.1 so it's just going to be negative
0.1 so it's going to be negative
zero point one and of course we can
simplify this a little bit this is going
to be equal to if we take 80 times 2 is
160 times negative zero point one that's
going to be negative 16 160 times 0.1 is
16 so negative 16 times times 1 minus
0.1 T and if we want we could distribute
the 16 or we could just leave it like
this but we're ready now to answer our
questions we could write it we could
write this is the rate of change of the
number of words we know with respect to
time or we could use the alternate
notation we could say this is w prime of
T either way it's going to be equal to
this thing it's negative let me do that
same color it's equal to negative 16
negative 16 times 1 minus 0.1 T so
what's this going to be what is the rate
of change of the of the number of words
known per day two days after studying
for the test well we just have to
evaluate this one T is equal to 2 so W
prime of 2 do that in magenta W prime of
2 is going to be equal to whoops well
I'll just go with the magenta is equal
to negative 16 negative 16 times 1 minus
0.1 times 2 times 2 close parenthesis
and that's going to be equal to well
let's see what is this this is 1 minus
essentially 0.2 this is going to be 0.8
so this is going to be equal to negative
16 times is that right 1 minus 0.2 is
yep it's going to be times 0.8 and what
is that going to be if I were to
multiply 16 times 8 it would be 128 it's
2 times 8 times 8 so 2 times 64 128 so
this is going to be negative
negative 12.8 and just to really hit the
point home of what we're doing this is
we're going to its negative the number
of words wean the rate of change is
negative twelve point eight words words
per day so if you believe this model for
how many words we know on a given day
this is saying on day two hour or right
right at the day two point right after
two exactly two days after studying for
the test I'm going to be right at that
moment I am I am essentially losing
twelve point eight words per day the
number of words I know is decreasing by
twelve point eight words per day